That might have been tricky. The answer should look something like this. There
might be other ways to do it, but I think this is the simplest one. If you
didn't get this, it's okay. There's more practice coming up. There are some
subtletles to how this method works, so let's go through an example. Let's say
we have two variables, one for Maria and one for Jamesha. Each of those should
contain a person object with a name and friends. We have string objects. For
Maria's name, Maria's current friends, Jamesha's name and Jamesha's current
friends. Let's say we call maria.addFriend(jamesha). We call this method on the
maria object and we pass in as an argument the Jamesha object. Now, when this
line runs, the first thing that it does is creates a new string from these
ones. This will be the new string that's created. It's going to put together
friends, friend.name, and a space. Friends is the friends of the maria object
because that's what we called the method on. So, we go to the Maria object, and
friends is currently just TJ, with a space. friend.name is the friend, the
argument, which was the Jamesha object, dot name, which is Jamesha. And the
space is just a space. So, when these strings get put together, it'll look like
TJ Jamesha. Now the string created by this part will be assigned into the
friends variable. So, the old reference will go away and a new one will be
created. And now, Jamesha appears in the friends of Maria. The old friends
string that contained just TJ might still be around. And it hasn't changed, but
the friends variable in the Maria object now contains a reference to a
different string.